une petite révolution comme aux portes
du monde laitier canadien des experts
recommandent au cours des années à venir
de donner plus de liberté de mouvement
aux vaches pour améliorer leur bien-être
ce n'est pas le cas présentement
particulièrement au québec où la
majorité des vaches sont attachés
[Musique]
dave kelly un producteur laitier de
saint nazaire de dorchester dans
chaudière appalaches élève ses vaches
selon le modèle dominant au québec la
stabulation entravée
ça veut dire que les animaux passent
leur vie entière attaché dans une étable
ses vaches là où celui-ci sort jamais
d'appui sont autant cacher ses seins
pratiquement tout le temps tu as chaud
sont pas très mobile fois très mobiles
non c'est
c et c'est la façon autrefois
stabulation entravée
au québec 72% des vaches sont élevées de
cette façon comparativement à 44 % au
canada
ce que déplore le vétérinaire edwin
quigley c'est ce qu'elle québec qu'on
reste dans nos amitiés notre façon de
faire ce qu'on connaît il ya beaucoup
folklore un peu dur à nassau parce qu'on
est habitués personne ne sait ce que
sont nos regards des vaches attachées
dans quatre par 6 à la nécropole place
notamment quelque chose et ce quelque
chose c'est la liberté de mouvement au
canada les vaches qui passent leur vie
dans des stalles entravé ont plus de
blessures qu'avec d'autres systèmes
d'élevage
43% problèmes aux genoux et 56% au
jarret il faut dire que les recouvrement
de sol sont parfois trop abrasif et que
les stalles sont souvent trop petites
dans ces conditions les collisions ou
les éraflures sont inévitables lever
coucher 700 kg d'uchaud par jour c'est
un défi fou ce soit bien fait puisque
ces gros muret de béton la même pas trop
d'impôts trop pas trop épais quand le
vétérinaire quigley est arrivé dans la
vie de dave kelly il ya un an les choses
ont commencé à changer
le producteur laitier voulait donner un
coup de barre certaines de ces vaches ne
se portait pas bien on vire warin aux
chroniques cephalon inquiets la pitié
plus rien qu'on peut faire ici on a une
bonne d'information nous aurait séduit
liquide finalement que d'un seul et pas
vraiment des factions mais sa force de
frotter à fait comme un genou douloureux
un couteau qu'on met un peu comme nous
on sait quelle sauce a cédé 6 9 h laudes
à son port ses belles conforte ap
optimum
ici c'est quoi la première
recommandation vous avez fait on a on a
voulu changer la surface de plancher on
a enlevé les luttes apim le lit très
bien mais les lycéens pendaison en plus
pour éviter l'abrasion puis après ce vol
et nos wagons en libye sur le futur
parce que ça c'est fait début 2000 21
nono state s'est améliorée
beaucoup de moins de deux blessés
beaucoup de vaches plus belle on attend
quelques vaches son poids qui met les
lésions sont l'homme et les nouvelles on
se développe est bien mais ça valait
mieux donc monsieur kelis cvo nouveauté
c'est sûr depuis que l'installation
c'est que on arrêter d'envoyer des
vaches à la réforme à cause de problèmes
d'atteinte de genoux des hanches
tissu la somme est vue du confort des
marchés je voudrais après la traite
toutes les vaches ont clos une verge
fait du gain qui est couché et nos gains
élevés le jour des vaches qui ont
provoqué qui ont une belle peau qui sont
heureuses petits font leur job ma job a
cédé rendent à faire le job se contente
les éditions tout le monde arrive à la
même conclusion ce que les vaches - 2 -
botosani moderne vous écrivant un mot
notre société on les dit qu'on fin
d'exercice ou d'exercice on veut garder
des risques il faut foncer vers nous
est ce que les consommateurs réalisent
donc elles conditionnent nos vaches
teisseire sont élevées entre autres au
québec moi je le pense pas enfin moi je
pense qu'ils ont convaincu qu'ils
modèrent médicaux des pompiers
mais je trouve ça déplorable
vraiment quelle que ce soit un animal
que ça soit un être humain c'est pas une
condition
des personnes qui méritent de filles de
cette façon de
vientiane
la liberté de mouvement c'est quelque
chose qui est quelque part très fort
dans la demande des consommateurs
elles savent açores est une spécialiste
du bien-être des vaches laitières ces
recherches sont financées par les
producteurs de lait des gens sensibles
aux influences sociétale
moi je pense que si les producteurs on a
décidé d'investir autant dans de la
recherche pour essayer d'améliorer le
système de stabulation entravée c'est
qu'effectivement il y avait un besoin de
répondre à des questionnements de la
part de leur tout sommateurs ça c'est
vrai
l'excellence d'aujourd'hui en fait c'est
on veut essayer de comprendre mais
bénéficie de donner accès à une cour
d'exercice en fait aux vaches laitières
spécifiquement pour les stabulation
entravée elles restent dans leur groupe
de trois et elle reste là pendant une
heure et nous on va regarder qu'est ce
qui se passe donc on a un collecteur de
données sur les pattes d'un certain
nombre de nos animaux pour mesurer le
nombre de pas
les vaches ont tout d'abord été sortie
une heure par jour cinq fois par semaine
sans surprise cet exercice à améliorer
la capacité de l'animal à se déplacer on
a vu un homme une amélioration du score
de locomotion mais on a vu quelque chose
d'extraordinaire c'est à dire qu'on a vu
une amélioration d'un point sur une
échelle de 5 un point c'est énorme
l'autre chose extrêmement importante au
niveau des pieds des monts c'est qu'on a
trouvé que l'effet bénéfique
de la sorte ils étaient encore huit
semaines
après la fin de l'expérience donc ce à
dire qu'il ya quand même un effet long
terme l'équipe tels ça maintenant des
sorties moins fréquentes qui serait
moins contraignante pour les producteurs
laitiers donc notre objectif c'était de
diaba finalement si on fait moins est-ce
qu'on retourne les mêmes bénéfices et
c'est ça qu'on est en train de regarder
si on fait moins ce que trois fois par
semaine c'est suffisant et une fois
qu'est ce que ça donne pour l'instant
seuls 6% des vaches du québec élevé en
stabulation entravée ont taxé à ce genre
de parc d'exercice
je pense qu'à long terme on veut tout
dire la stabulation libre pour thomas
donné meilleur confort ni la stabulation
libre c'est un mode de production où les
vaches peuvent circuler à leur guise à
l'intérieur d'une étable à aire ouverte
elles ont des logements individuels ou
manger et se reposer un système dont le
vétérinaire a entendu parler lors d'un
congrès en europe il ya 30 ans lors il
fallait se présenter et qui dit qu'elle
soit de troupeaux conduit au saccage de
90% de mes vaches est attaché ça l'a
fait te soutenons la salle puis on dit
que ça de mono c'est sûr parce qu il
ajouté les teintes de jaune libre vous
passez pour arriérés ou quoi exemple
avec la stabulation libre la boiterie
les blessures au cou au genou et au
jarret sont beaucoup moins fréquentes
mais seulement 28% des vaches du québec
sont élevées de cette façon deux fois
moins que la moyenne canadienne il faut
dire que la stabulation libre commandes
de gros investissements parce que ses
étables sont davantage automatisés ça
prend deux plus gros troupeau pour
supporter financièrement ce modèle or
les troupeaux québécois sont de petite
taille
souvent il faut bâtir un bâtiment qui
est le double de pieds carrés parler
d'une moyenne au québec de 75 vaches
laitières on est un relais de beaucoup
inférieure à la moyenne canadien qui est
plus aux alentours de 120 vaches c'est
clair que le frein je vous dirais que
c'est au niveau de la rentabilité oui on
fait ce choix-là d'investir sur une
ferme il faut le faire dans les bonnes
conditions
dave kelly lui est sur le point de se
tourner vers la stabulation libre pour
une partie de ses opérations
il construit une nouvelle section pour
la mise bas de ses vaches pour l'instant
elle accouche enchaîné comme dans la
majorité des troupeaux du québec élevé
en stabulation entravée sans compter que
dans le corps des troupeaux les vaches
doivent mettre bas dans leurs stalles
régulière comme ici chez dave kelly
c'est en mai que la vache qui se prépare
à delhi alain grousset locales et la
plus grosse dans sa dans son âne il sait
que c'est le conte devant nos plus
grands du talent nos vaches font couché
dans une seule pollution elle peut même
pas se retourner facilement et sans
déranger au
[Musique]
tpr et du combiné les mots par park
baisse à environ 4 on avait mis des
petits boulots et s'arrêtera non pour
moi je pense que ça va être mieux qu est
ce qu ont ils au prochain milliard aux 5
milliard c'est pour l'aca pour ça et
half ans yacine on
a toujours deux points
on
de nos jours la très vaste majorité des
producteurs laitiers québécois qui
bâtissent une nouvelle étable opte
d'emblée pour la stabulation libre les
vaches attachées l'eau toute leur vie
c'est de moins en moins fréquents je
voudrais qu'on tend à éliminer cette
pratique le bien-être animal je pense
qu'on est à la croisée des chemins ce
rattrapage est dans rennes se fait il
moi ce que je peux vous rassurer le
client et produit tous les risques avec
ces des gens qui sont très très fier qui
veulent reprendre cet écart loeb qui
veulent être là parmi les leaders au
niveau du canada
je pense qu'un animal c'est comme un
instrument allons talent de loi de
connaître humain de vivre de bien vive
oui c'est vrai qu'il ya des gens qui
vont en penser qu'on les utilise comme
une machine
moi je pense que c'est pour ça
mais il faut qu'elle soit et bien dans
ce cas leurs affaires et puis je
penserai à porter